Hàng trong người và bật cảm này chờ đủy sế phép lại sẻ ở Hàng Nội.
Sợ quá, cái công cuộc, cái gì lấy số này?
Đưa đưa thấy rất là kinh khủ quá.
Mui hai ra cảm, nó bị ra đi xe hả?
Bây giờ mình lòng mới lý được số đấy, thợ phòng nhẹ nhau.
Nếu anh được hả, nếu anh được hả, nếu anh được hả?
Chứ cái vám, đây là là hả?
Ví thả mình đang ngủ đu dụt,
trời tay là chánh thủ trời ra ăn,
thang của mình đã còn khoảng 2,5 con nữa là hết hả?
Cái không ơn rồi, và thời điểm này đi lúc mà nó quá hạm thì ra...
Hãy đi học lại nó còn bất cả hơn.
Cái của phúc biết là có đến rửa không có bất cả,
nhưng mà...
Với tí đệnh thì quán bất cả, phải tí là ai đưa đây là mình vụ phải bất cả,
phải chỉ có nó có mấy tí làm chứ này,
mới xưa lời quá, bà tháng thì nó có tí là lợt thì.
Này thì tôi vẫn đang khi chỉ công tác cái nhận của tôi có đối lệ xin,
thì nó lời xem, phải nó sẽ bị gõ.